for
e
prime minister of are
dear colleagues we have uh the prime
minister of Bulgaria Nikolai denov uh
with us today prime minister uh welcome
to the European Parliament thank you for
being here uh special welcome also I see
her now walking in to Maria Gabrielle
the Deputy Prime Minister whom we know
so well in this house uh prime minister
this is the first time you are here
since uh we have seen uh the
conclusion um of the critical
governmental rotation agreement in
Bulgaria that finally managed to break
through the political deadlock and gave
Bulgaria an important perspective
stability and European Outlook and for
that that we are grateful 16 years of
European union membership have been
transformative for Bulgaria and for
Europe it has given new impetus for
businesses for industry for science for
technology it has brought opportunities
for people and for young people in
particular it has brought more social
and judicial benefits and reforms
because EU membership promotes equality
social justice democracy and the rule of
law and in times of geopolitical change
these European values must be defended
dear prime minister I would like to
particularly thank Bulgaria for its
support for Ukraine for providing
military aid for providing military
political support Europe is stronger
thanks to Bulgaria and your government
and will be stronger still when you join
the Euro Zone and finally take your
rightful place in the shenen area
[Applause]
next June 6.8 million bulgarians will be
called upon to choose the 17 elected
members of the European Parliament who
will represent them here we must work
together to make sure people understand
why they must vote why it is important
their voice matters for the European
Union and Bulgaria's future and we must
keep listening and keep delivering prime
minister the floor is
yours Madame President of the European
Parliament
presidents of uh
parliamentary political
groups representative of the council
Madame commissioner ladies and gentlemen
it's an honor and privilege for me to be
here among you representatives of United
Europe in this
beautiful
city just days
after the end of the second world war
the French army entered Strasburg and
tomorrow also we will be celebrating the
aniversary
of from the day when Strasburg was
liberated from Nazi occupation Strasburg
is a city with a tulous and Rich history
it was part of the Roman Empire then it
was part of the whole Roman Empire it
was briefly an independent city and over
the past two centuries it was either
French or a
German a city Strasburg is known as a
city of roads and in the past these
roads saw more soldiers and TKS than
Traders and
peaceful citizens in the past to be at
the
crossroads was rather a curse not a
blessing in the past these roads
separated people today they unite people
in the past the sky over Strasburg
was wounded by fighter jets by boms and
now we
see commercial airplanes also Kites and
uh children
balloon today Strasburg symbolizes peace
in the past julus seasar Shan Napoleon
Hitler and Stalin tried to unite Europe
through Conquest through Wars through
the force of weapons and the more
cruel these words
were the shorter the time of their
success stories was today Europe is
united in peace being
a union of equal
partners and the values of democracy
rule of law human rights are upheld as
well as human dignity and rights of each
and every citizen you work in
Strasburg you are the parliament of the
United Europe you are the guarantor of
upholding European values my country is
one of the most ancient countries in
Europe since
681 we have been called Bulgaria in its
history
Bulgaria was part of the Byzantine
Empire and it was part of the Ottoman
Empire almost
five centuries but our country was able
to resurrect thanks to those who
initiated and carried out the Bulgarian
national Revival in the 19th century one
of them is our national hero vasil leki
he is the person who inspired the
European Spirit of Bulgaria he said that
Bulgaria should be
a Democratic Republic where all ethnic
groups bulgarians Turks Jews everyone
would be equal in all meanings in all
areas of life and everyone would live
according to the law upon which everyone
has
agreed and our well-being he said
depends on our United concertive efforts
I think that it is hardly to add
something to this in its modern history
Bulgaria was subject two attempts to be
dominated some of them were successful I
mean here Russia and the Soviet Union
unfortunately these Imperial Ambitions
of Russia continue up to today our
country is a target of hybrid attacks
Putin's Russia tries to use our economic
ties between Bulgaria and Russia and
also the traditional cultural links
between the Bulgarian and the Russian
peoples that's
why the fully fledged membership of
Bulgaria in the European Union and NATO
is the guarantee of the
European way and development of our
country that's why we need to finalize
our accession to to the euro area and
the shenen area I would like here to
thank all MEPS who supported Bulgaria in
its ambition to join shenen this is a
cause which means European Justice
European fairness Bulgaria has always
been part and parcel not only of
military achievements of Europe I would
like to remind you that Bulgaria was the
state that stopped the EUR Arab
Invasion to Europe and also we were part
of the European Enlightenment part of
this is the cilic alphabet which was
created by two bulgarians our ambition
is Bulgaria of today to give its
meaningful contribution to the
development and growth of the European
Union we understand
that the new member countries especially
the poor ones the European Union is
usually perceived by a place from which
funds come and where people can find
better paid jobs but we need to break
this stereotype that's why I would like
to remind us all of the words of JF
Kennedy don't ask what the European
Union could do for your country ask what
your country what you could do for the
European Union ladies and gentlemen
unfortunately the European Union is not
an isolated island of well-being and
peace we have a devastating war on our
doorstep we see how Putin's Russia wants
to crush the
Ukrainian the Ukrainian people's will to
live independently in peace the conflict
in in the Middle
East caused by the brutal atrocities of
Hamas against the peaceful Israeli
citizens and then we saw also the
reaction of Israel which also led to
loss of human lives
including those of women and children we
need to take into account also the
unstable situation in Lebanon uh Jordan
and Iraq and also we mustn't for forget
about the situation in Afghanistan where
T Taliban is in power also Iran is
threatening the International Community
with its nuclear
program there is a huge risk also
stemming from the heightening tensions
between China and taian we also can see
that also in Africa gavon Chad guine
B so
K committed by the military it is
worrying that some of these
Ceta were performed by The crucial role
of the private military company Wagner
and also we can see that Civil War
continues in Libya Ethiopia and so
Somalia we saw also
numerous murderous terrorist attacks in
many
other African countries these all
signals that our world is very
unstable we cannot neglect all these
geopolitical challenges to face them to
address them Europe needs to be strong
and for this it needs to be
United the wrong two main political
ideologies in uh Europe conservatism and
liberalism and they should strive for
Mutual understanding and cooperation the
borders of our countries the history and
traditions of our Nations Christianity
and family are conservative values which
are still needed in our world today the
borders of Europe that have become so
visible uh now because of the migrant
crisis and the war of Ukraine emphasize
even more these conservative values but
the world is becoming more and more
Global and the liberal ideas also are
taking root in international
cooperation politics culture the rights
of women minorities people who are
different from
majorities are part of liberal democracy
we need to turn our back on the extremes
and we need to be
United around the most important values
conservative and liberal ones we need to
fight the polarization as a political
platform to come to power only thus will
we be able to regain the confidence of
our citizens a United and strong Europe
should be more active on the
international arena being a reliable
guarantor of Peace at the same time the
European Union needs
to Foster
its cooperation with strategic Partners
including first and foremost Partners
from NATO and needs to consider the need
for a single European
Army ladies and gentlemen given the
complex International situation the the
enlargement of the European Union
becomes even more relevant and important
Bulgaria has always been strongly in
favor for the accession of Western
Balkan countries to the European Union
at the same time we believe that these
states should become EU member states
only when they meet all criteria their
accession should be based on the Merit
on their sincere will to become real
members of the European family we
welcome the decision of the European
commission to launch the negotiations
for accession with Ukraine and mova we
hope that Georgia will join this group
soon the European Union does need
fostering and strengthening of its
institution and also enlargement but we
believe that the accession of new
countries should go hand inand with the
enhancement of EU institutions the
reports on rule of law are a very good
guarantee for control and also this is
important for candidate countries all
waves of enlargement of the European
Union have shown
that the larger the EU becomes the
more powerful and strong it is today in
Europe we can see a certain fatigue from
the war in Ukraine and uh we can see the
diminishing of Aid to Ukraine and
Ukrainian refugees more and more
Europeans are asking the questions why
should we support a nation at War and a
which is not an EU member states isn't
it better
to ensure peace and uh many people say
that even bad unstable peace is better
than the best of the best war and uh we
remember what Winston Churchill said
with regard to the Munich Accords of
1938 those who do not remember the past
are condemned are doomed to repeating it
we remember how all attempts finished
when there were attempts to appease
Hitler
actually Putin's war against Ukraine is
a war against Europe when we defend
protect Ukraine we defend and protect
Europe
otherwise tomorrow mova could become a
new Ukraine the other day
the Baltic states Poland Romania
Bulgaria and other European
countries esteemed
Ms a consequence of wars and instability
is also the rise in
migration due to Europe being such an
attractive place the vast majority of
people seeking Refuge go to Europe but
the European
Union is not capable of welcoming an
unlimited number of migrants without
this threatening its institutions
imigrant moreover the integration of
those already in uh Europe uh is quite a
slow process there are incidents uh
committed by radicalized elements many
of them B forign and bread within the
European union we need a new strategy
that will make a clear distinction
between War refugees and economic
migrants the European Union has to make
all efforts to integrate refugees and uh
to discourage and stop illegal and
economic migration we need to strike the
proper balance between security
and uh the opportunities uh that U are
given to them hopefully all these
challenges will be reflected in the new
migration and
Asylum package Bulgaria has met all the
criteria for accession to the shenen
area any further delays of our accession
are
unacceptable and they cannot be
understood by uh the Bulgarian general
public many countries reintroduce their
border controls but they cannot be
Arguments for the failure to accept
Bulgaria into the shenen area with
Bulgaria within shenen European borders
will be better protected and Europe will
be
stronger ladies and gentlemen finally I
would like to remind you of a story of
solidarity on the 5th of March
2022 just a few days after the Russian
aggression in Ukraine the official
website of the Slovak please publish the
following
notice an
11-year-old boy from the zapo
roier crossed the border on foot
with the passport hanging from his neck
the telephone number and a
small nylon bag in his
hand he came alone because his mother
had to
remain in Ukraine my name's Hassan said
the boy and I alone I had to come to
Slovakia alone he's mother saw him off
at the railway
station and he went on with his
story we have long experience with
moving and Crossing Borders we were oued
from our homes uh uh by the Russians in
uh
Syria and the only thing
her son could rely on was the telephone
number of his elder
brother the mother said I could not
accompany my son because I'm crippled
Julia vladimirova was the name of the
mother that is a
hero the child
walked
over
1,000
kilomet some of that
distance was
covered on trains
but threat of bombing was his sole
companion but there were no tears in the
eyes of this uh young her
he even tried to
smile this is the human tragedy behind
the dry
statistics um cited in the
media ladies and
gentlemen I started my speech with the
symbols of the past and the future allow
me to mention a few more memorable
events to today we celebrate the
anniversary of the first president of
the fth Republic General charl deal on
the 23rd of November
1959 president
deal delivered his famous speech from
the Atlantic to the euro expressing his
vision that Europe will be a single hole
throughout this vast
territory the Cold War
was at its peak from stretching the
Baltic seed to the Mediterranean
triest that
sounded
absurd it might sound absurd today when
Ukrainian men women and children die it
could
equally be absurd but when
lukashenka Putin and all uh the others
uh will be bygone when there are no
young Heroes with just the passport
hanging from their uh neck and a
telephone number written on their Palm
we will have free Democratic and United
Europe thank
you thank you very much
we will now start with the speakers of
the different political groups starting
with the EP group uh I give the floor
for 2 a half minutes to
Andre thank you madam president Madame
commissioner dear coings I would like to
welcome Mr denov Miss Gabriel I'm very
happy that you are here Among Us
Bulgaria has a pro European predictable
stable government whose prime minister
you are and this is thanks to the wise
policy carried out by the citizens for
European development of Bulgaria party
and its chairperson Mr biss of it is
very important that every EU member
State should have a pro-european stable
predictable govern government
unfortunately uh the elections and uh
the delay in uh forming the government
led to the
delays uh
to receive EU funds which was felt by
all Bulgarian
citizens and uh also I am very happy
that you haven't lost sopia the capital
in the recent local elections we will as
a party continue being a guarantor of
stable pro-european development of
Bulgaria we also will do everything
to REM
to eliminate all remains of our
communist past and also we uh will fight
the influence of some Russian oligarchs
and especially L oil which is so
important for the kremlin's budget I
would like to thank Miss Gabrielle for
her
efforts so that Bulgaria can join the
shenen area I would like to thank Miss
Gabriel for her
excellent
speech and also for her efforts leading
to Bulgaria becoming member of the UN
Human Rights Council I think that it is
very good that pro-democratic political
forces in Bulgaria have managed to set
up a government and I hope that
cooperating with you Mr denov we will
will continue going successfully towards
the establishment of Bulgaria as a fully
fledged member of the EU which will
contribute to the political security of
Bulgaria and of the EU V one
minute thank you madam
president Mr Prime Minister your welcome
to the European
Parliament today there will be some
indicative vote on possible amendments
to the EU
treaties including the decisions related
to the enlargement so I would like to
ask you about the position of the
Bulgarian uh
government on uh the
rule of the qualified majority vote or a
unanimous vote on matters of enlargement
you mentioned mova and
Ukraine will the negotiations with them
affect the position of the countries in
the western Balkans this should not be a
disincentive for them thank
you thank you thank you Mr vitanov and
now on behalf of the renew Europe group
Mr Stefan seun for two
minutes
Madame
President prime minister and dear
colleagues thank
you prime minister for your highly
pro-european
speech your government has been a breath
of fresh air for Bulgaria and
particularly for the European aspects
thereof that's what I want to talk about
today uh I say your government is pro-
European it's a progressive one it's
very welcome breath of fresh air uh and
uh when it comes to specific support for
Ukraine in the face of the uh Russian
attacka this is also welcome your
position and so my political family
supports your stance and I'd like to
take this opportunity also to State how
responsible your party has shown itself
to be having set up a coalition despite
the uh differences obtaining uh this in
the interest of your country and
especially of Europe in these
institutions people have often felt very
fatalistic about certain uh of uh
Bulgaria's difficulties when it comes to
combating corruption or combating
climate change or or the uh our
continent's Unity on the international
front but it has to be said that the
reform of your government
uh by your predecessors after your
predecessors and with you a lot of
criticisms uh have been tempered now and
we're working together really uh with a
an eye on a green and Innovative future
for Europe and one where there's
solidarity with Europe uh Ukraine uh
sovereignty and in this Europe of
tomorrow uh Bulgaria has a key place
when it comes to uh our perspective of
enlargement to the uh
Balkans as you know some of us are very
much in favor of that and uh it's high
time that Bulgaria with its Romanian
neighbor be allowed into the shenen area
we should not frustrate the hopes of the
bulgarians in that regard and I I launch
a call to my colleagues in the EP
turning to my colleague uh you know that
we in Ru have done our part we have
tried to assist our uh allies in the
decision to allow Bulgaria into uh the
uh shenen area we need the pp to win
over their allies as well there are
those who are still uh opposing the
idea so prime
minister uh you will always have a
friend and an ally and somebody
supporting you in your efforts in renew
Europe thank you to take the floor for
three minutes can I please ask you to
keep to the
time good ahead Mr Prime Minister we
were born
actually Mr Prime Minister I know that
Maria Gabriel has more attractiveness to
you than me but um because she's your
partner in government
we were born actually 6 months apart and
when we were born we were separated You
and I by an iron curtain and it remains
to me a deep joy to see that all two
countries are now part of the same Union
and it's a union as you said of choice
of freedom and based on rule of law and
like you uh and maybe you didn't say it
explicitly but I really resent when some
European politicians are comparing the
European Union to the new Soviet Union
or to A Renewed third right where we
would be submitted by force we all chose
freely to be part of that Union and that
remains a source of Pride and let no one
believe that the European Union is a
repetition of the past uh failures in
Europe the second thing I I I want to
say is that I totally agree with you
when you say that what is happening in
Ukraine is basically the defense of the
values on which the European Union has
been built this is our struggle and I
must say that yes it entails effort from
the uh uh members of the European Union
to help Ukraine but Frankly Speaking
they are putting their lives on the line
we are just putting part of our wealth
to help them and I think that's the
least we can do third thing where I
agree with you is that yes the European
Union is a union freely chosen but it
has to be Merit based and there again
when the merits are there the decision
should follow yes Bulgaria and Romania
must be part of shenen and for Citizens
this is probably with the common
currency the most
emblematic meaning of what it means to
be part of the European Union so full
support for that I will finish with the
values you mentioned a lot the
conservative and liberal values and then
the Green in me said hang on one second
yes the conservatives and the Liberals
have brought a lot to Europe but I think
that there's more to European political
diversity and values diversity than just
those two families I think that the the
the left has brought the this value of
social justice and that lies at the
heart of the European Union and I would
finish with the thing that was most
absent from your speech well you know if
you and I and our kids and grandkids
will live in the 21st century and beyond
well it is it will be because we have
been able to protect this planet as our
common home and indeed that lies as well
at the heart of the values of the
European Union making sure that indeed
the planet on which we live will be
welcoming us for generations to come
thank you very much thank you very much
Mr Lambert and now Angel jaski for four
minutes thank you Madame
President
colleagues Mr
prime minister you started with
some references to history but they were
rather partial let's not forget that on
this
date many years ago but not so many the
western parts of Bulgaria were occupied
and uh there were atrocities against
Bulgarian uh people
bulgarians and uh thanks to churches
intervention an end was put on it you
cited JF
Kennedy but you meet to ask the question
what does the Bulgarian government do to
Bulgarian citizens because it's not the
EU bureaucrats but the Bulgarian
citizens who employ you and you should
serve them you said that now in the
skies of Strasburg we could see
children's skes white doves and so on
but what
Bulgarian bulgarians see they see
inflation high prices they are
struggling to make ends meet and you as
prime minister
should not not allow that the Bulgarian
citizens suffer from high prices from
inflation this is not European this is
hypocrisy this is a double standard you
are not uh uh a director of a tourist
agency you are a prime minister of a
member state of the EU we you also
referred to Ukraine yes it is necessary
to support Ukraine but also we need to
support not only Bulgarian citizens in
Bulgaria but also we need to support
ethnic bulgarians in North
Macedonia and there are people who turn
a blind eye to the violence against
bulgarians in North
Macedonia and this is a problem but you
should say to North Macedonian
government you should stop violence
against ethnic bulgarians these are
European values and you should say to
Bulgarian diplomats to do this and also
in the court of human rights in
Strasburg we also need to protect
bulgarians
and
when
kovo saw also searches and uh also
violence of serbs in against serbs in
Kosovo you did nothing you said that you
will investigate what has been happening
with State subsidies you should do this
it is necessary to check where subsidies
are going who is the beneficiary
about transport
companies you also spoke about Africa
Mali Chad and so on but you're a
Bulgarian prime minister and you need to
focus on the interest and well-being of
Bulgarian citizens and their access to
uh freedom of
movement their access to European
prospects so I wish you to be in good
health but politically speaking you will
need to have a very strong backbone and
you need to be absolutely adamant
defending Bulgarian interest in the
interest of all bulgarians thank you
thank you very much next speaker on
behalf of the identity and democracy
group Mr Beck please thank you president
uh honorable prime minister allow me to
congratulate you on your decision to
order an investigation
into the 2023 Bulgarian Turkish gas deal
concluded by your
predecessor the southern gas Corridor we
all know is used to launder Russian gas
via turkey and to circumvent EU
sanctions which so far have very little
effect on the Russian
economy forgive me sorry the European
commission knows this full well as its
400 million EUR subsidy agreement
with uh with the gas Corridor contains a
secrecy clause which prohibits any probe
into the Providence of the gas in other
words Prime former prime minister
borisov was given a free license to laer
Russian gas in return for his loyal
support for Mrs Merkel and her party
throughout his years in the
council moreover under the gas deal
bulgar gas has to pay turkey's
state-owned gas company Bas an annual
service fee of2
billion northern European citizens are
paying cohesion funds to Bulgaria which
Bulgaria that appears to be handing over
to erduan EU policy it seems is ridded
with
hypocrisy on Bulgarian accession to
shagen I agree with the position taken
by the Austrian and Dutch governments we
need to reform shenen before we can talk
about shagan
expansion there's also the regrettable
issue of Bulgarian officials selling
shagan visas to Illegal migrants of
course the main culprit here is Germany
which is creating pull factors for
migrants to enter via southern Europe in
resisting credible rules for push back
and comprehensive
repatriation of Il of illegal migrants
we therefore call on the Bulgarian
government to help us in the fight for
ambitious migration reform in the EU
then I can't imagine your application
finally to join the shagan system would
pose too many problems thank
you thank you next speaker on behalf of
the left group Mr willamson the floor is
yours
president uh commissioner and prime
minister this is Europe a Europe where
we stood United in solidarity with
Ukraine after the brutal attack by Putin
a Europe that has imposed sanctions
against Putin for his grave violations
against international law and human
rights a Europe that actively has
engaged in making sure that war crimes
in Ukraine will be be prosecuted dear
colleagues this is a Europe I'm proud of
but when we look at the horrors
unfolding in Gaza and the response of
the European Union we have clearly
failed we stood United in condemning the
brutal terror attack of Hamas good we
have stood United in a call for
immediately releasing of all h hostages
good but we have failed in protecting
the innocent children and people of Gaza
they have died by the thousands those
alive are struggling to survive if they
live they will be
traumatized this is Europe and this
Europe has for years failed to speak up
against the Israeli violations of
international law fa failed to speak out
against the human rights violations that
Palestinians in the occupied territories
daily suffer failed to pressure for a
sustainable two-state solution where
both Israelis and Palestinians can live
in peace and prosperity side by side
dear colleagues dear prime minister
Europe can do better let this Europe be
a Europe of strong values a Europe that
speak out for international laws in all
matter a Europe that speak out against
killing of civilians whoever they are a
Europe that speak out for peace and
prosperity for both the people of Israel
and
Palestine thank you next speaker
MRSA the floor is yours
please
uh honorable prime minister Dan kov and
Mrs
Gabrielle uh yes I want to start with
also uh acknowledging what Philip told
that I was a little bit surprised when
you spoke about conservatism and liberal
values not mentioning social values
while President M solo spoke about but
nevertheless I have to remind that
Bulgarian presidency when it took place
in the beginning of 2018 supported our
proposed guidelines for employment
policies in the member states I was a
reporter that time and thanks to that
directive on minimum wage appeared but
our proposal was more ambitious and what
do you think about proposal of minimum
income for EU and I have to
remind that Bulgaria is the state where
the in the bottom of least of minimum
wage smaller minimum wages as my country
as well yeah another question is about
rights and about rights of minorities
you spoke about vasil leki uh mentioning
bulgarians Jews and Turks as equal but
what happed Happ s now what do you think
about the rights of minorities
especially the rights to participate in
election campaign in their own language
we know the decision of the European Kur
where Bulgaria lost and the the problem
the same problem exists in my country
Lea as well
abolishing education abolishing rights
to speak speak in pre-election campaign
in minority languages it is not the
Europe you mentioned as a Europe uniting
United in diversity means not only Unity
of 27 member states but also of all
languages of all cultures within
European unions thank you thank you very
much next speaker colleague Mr ranel the
FL is
yours
thank you share dear prime minister dear
commissioner
Ivanova I would like to say that
Bulgaria is a country whose history is
intertwined with Europe and it is really
in the origin of the DNA of Europe from
its ancient times to Modern Times your
country gave us the alphabet of sanil
and methodus and you are speaking in a
very clear way the language of Freedom
after
1990 so it's a pleasure to have it's
really something that completes the
European project to have Bulgaria in the
European Union and also in NATO and I I
also have to congratulate uh you uh and
Maria Gabrielle for the return of
political stability and responsible uh
uh Behavior a clear pro-european
government and I would like to say that
here Maria Gabrielle that is a very very
committed pro-european is a very
important active of your executive then
let me tell you that I understand the
difficulties in external landscape of a
country that has its Coast in the Black
Sea so close to the war but at the same
time it's very important to call on you
to step up your efforts to to end fossil
fuel dependence on Russia could you
clarify how you plan to close this
loophole on Russia oil we are here as
European Union to support you but we
need also your efforts in this field and
let let me tell you that we also a bit
worried with the European funds because
the instability of the last years
paralyzed the uh uh development and
implementation of these European funds
so what is the plan for the next two
years where you have a very very very
tiny uh uh time and only to say we are
totally with Bulgaria and with Romania
on your shenen section and we as EP we
already condemn the EP government that
is blocking that I hope that liberals
with Netherlands would do the same
especially after these
elections thank you very much next
speaker colleague MREs
[Applause]
please dear prime minister dear Deputy
Prime Minister Romania and Bulgaria
deserve to be accepted to the shenen
area and this needs to happen fully and
it needs to happen now it is
unacceptable for our two countries to be
left out even though we fulfill all the
shenen criteria and we have efficiently
protected the European borders for so
many years we live here prime minister
in a difficult region but we have always
defended European values and the
cohesion of our Union we did that during
difficult times in the western Balkans
we help build the safe Black Sea region
while maintaining a good relationship
with turkey Georgia and the countries in
the Black Sea and we are proving it once
more today with the support provided to
Ukraine and the Republic of mdova
Romania and Bulgaria are not second
ranked members and people should stop
looking at us this way that is why I
call upon the leaders to support our
accession to shenen all the way by
having a vote by the end of the year in
order to show that respecting the rules
in the EU pays off thank you thank you
very much next speaker colleague Mr cuk
the floor is
your thank you Mr President Mr Prime
Minister dear colleagues I have
participated many times in such debates
and they have always ended in the same
conclusion the bet on the internal
policy of Bulgaria let's do this
differently now let's not make it about
the domestic policy of Bulgaria but to
be about the future of Europe and let's
use this
pro-european majority to conduct the
reforms that are so necessary there is
one issue on which there is uh consensus
European
commission you Europe members of the
European Parliament they agree on the
issue of shenen if we don't join shenen
we are risking a lot as members of the
European Union we risk undermining the
foundations of everything that we have
achieved over the past 70 years because
the Bulgarian and Romanian citizens can
not continue to be treated as they have
been treated in the past years they're
not from the Austrian Dutch and other
citizens the Bulgarian economy is
suffering a lot if we want to have a
union based on a competitive economy um
Bulgaria and Romania need to be a member
of members of shenen and something else
that is very important I would like
Bulgaria to be ambitious with its ideas
plans and proposals that it submits to
the EU institutions we canot have a
European Union that wishes to have a
strong policy if our decision making is
as it is
now countries gather reach
decisions uh with procrastination and
haggling uh
especially countries that are uh like us
uh we need to change the system from
consensus to qualified
majority uh I know what uh some people
will sayhan kuk wishes to sneak the
Western Balkans in somehow therefore let
us be ambitious and responsible before
the future of the European Union because
it's the future of all of
us Mr B ofer the floor is
yours
president prime minister commission
colleagues I want to thank you primis
Denko for talking to us and with
us you dwelt quite extensively on
historic issues and you spoke about the
European Spirit of Bulgaria that your
national hero emphasized and I'm sure
all of us loved it you quoted JFK and I
like too so let me ask you this
question what will Bulgaria do for the
EU with regard to EU
enlargement you didn't mention the name
of your neighboring country North
Macedonia whose access so far has been
blocked by
Bulgaria in vague terms only you seemed
to question the real will of candidate
countries can anybody question the real
European will of North Macedonia a
country that even went as far as
changing its name in order to open the
door to
Europe after Mr jatski spute Hate
against North Macedonia here I would
like to ask you prime minister to be
more
specific what will you do to help
opening the door for North
Macedonia I believe Bulgaria must avoid
hampering the accession process with
overhyped national blockades thank
you thank you next speaker Mr
slov thank you Miss madam chair academic
denov Mrs Gabrielle commissioner I was
planning to speak on education and
culture but the way things are going I
will be speaking about shenen I am a
deputy chair of the culture committee
and I'd like to address all of those who
think that Bulgaria should not exceed
the shenen all of the illegal uh
smuggling channels have been funded by
the central European countries Austria
Germany these are not Bulgarian
trafficking channels and something else
that I'd like to say to my colleague
from the
greens when they beat up bulgarians they
uh don't let them self identify as
bulgarians don't say that
jasi uh um speech was a hate speech you
just don't understand what's happening
in Macedonia and now in Bulgaria the
budget for culture is
0.4 this education budget is 0.1 out of
of the national budget this is very
little a while ago in our committee we
voted that the minimum culture budget
should be
2% the way things are going we will
reach that percent in about 150
years I hope you have a plan with regard
to culture and education because these
things are very important they should be
a priority of ours thank you thank you
very much next speaker Mr Bimi the floor
is
yours
thank you thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen in the Germans speaking World
We tend to
say by the time we reach the evening
lazy people get
going and that reminds me of the types
of decisions we've taken recently you
know the decisions to be taken today
previous days also what we intend to
decide going forward I don't know
politically speaking it seems insane to
me
and I wanted to say a few words also
about the the history of this this is
Europe debate the background to it it
started with this Parliament and it
started I suppose with the lockdown
policy you know the consequences for the
continent the lockdown policy look at
what happened
unemployment businesses going bust and I
think uh psychologically it was a real
burden for a lot of people people 1.8
billion vaccines being purchased and I
know that the public prosecutors
officers are looking at those purchases
anyway this is really a failure a
failure of the European Union in a way
it started with that and then it
continues of course with Ukraine versus
Russia waves and waves of hundreds and
thousands of
sanctions and it seems to me we've
basically only shot ourselves in the
foot by taking such decisions again
unemployment businesses going bust and
so on and so forth we are going down the
wrong route it's a complete failure and
these measures are a complete failure so
let's take stock are we going to
continue like this with this kind of
insane way of proceeding you know the
green deal sounds nice it sounds nice on
paper but our competitiveness will be
lost as a European Union emobility the
question of nuclear energy you know all
of that politically speaking what you're
proposing is
insane
also we're talking about you know
possibly using insect protein in our
meals etc etc this is
absolutely incredible for me so when you
ask the question this is Europe is this
Europe well my reply would be this is a
Europe that is going completely down the
wrong track anyway we've got June coming
up next year I hope that there will be a
change a reasonable one at that point
Mrs da thank thank you very
much thanks president and thanks prime
minister for being here and for the
meetings you had with us and your
cabinet and your president on the recent
rule of law monitoring visit to Bulgaria
Bulgaria of course is the oldest
independent country in Europe a
magnificent place and people but for all
the hope that EU membership would help
transform it the truth is that it
Remains the poorest country in the EU EU
experiencing an 11% drop in population
as young people left to find
Opportunities elsewhere while scandal
after Scandal dogged previous
administrations Barcelona gate the eight
dwarfs the golden bars massive
corruption facilitated by the absolute
power of the prosecutor General and the
close collaboration with former prime
minister boyco borisov now your party
came out of the movement of the people
to change all that and that movement has
made changes but many issues remain and
I think it's really important that it's
put on record here that all of those
cases of those in power accused of
robbing the Bulgarian people will be
investigated those responsible held to
account and that there will be no
impunity lastly I agree with you totally
Bulgaria should be in shenen but I do
have a concern that the European
commission is demanding a price for that
that you act as Europe's brutal military
border guards in violation of Human
Rights there have been multiple accounts
of pushbacks we have a black book on
pushbacks here which I'm going to give
you as a present which I hope you read
to investigate the evidence in that and
ensure the upholding of Human Rights
thanks for being here thank you very
much next speaker colleague Mr novakov
the floor is
yours Madam chair
Mr Prime
Minister Madame commissioner dear
friends I'll make an effort to start off
with something positive I'd like to
thank Mr Denko for all of his efforts
for his pro-european Pro Atlantic
position on behalf of Bulgaria this was
obligatory and very important
unfortunately this is uh all I can say
in positive terms we need to go back to
the
predictability uh from
years ago and this was something that we
saw when we had Boo brov
Here unfortunately Bulgaria
was together with a group of countries
part of a group of countries where
stability was uh characteristic but this
is no longer the
case we now live amidst uh demands for
resignations political scandal Etc
investors would come and stay in
Bulgaria this is no longer the case this
may come as a surprise to you
but apart from asking who in Bulgaria we
also need to ask the question how much
how much uh of the European funds have
been uh paid out let me answer that for
you
2% how much of the funds under the
recovery and resiliance uh plan has been
paid out
3% how many many countries are in our
position zero not one we can continue
questioning what will
be the difference between the money
negotiating and the money that will
eventually reach our municipalities this
will be a big difference I think we need
to um address this issue of um making
sure that money gets to
Bulgarian municipalities this needs to
stop this need to stop transferring
funds from the previous program
programming period we need to stop
repurposing uh
funds this is why based on article
I ask the European commission to make
sure that Bulgaria will not lose any
funds from the recovery and resilience
Plans by applying implementing a
schedule we need a plan for Investments
we should not ass say here uh
declarations but rather results thank
you the floor is
yours thank you Madame President uh Mr
Prime Minister the government that
you're heading uh excuses its uh
presence with several goals shenen
membership and the Euro Zone and the
need of stability in the complex
geopolitical situation on a domestic
plan we need to see whether the idea of
the changes in the Judiciary will become
true the aims uh are uh seem to be to uh
injure the image of the Bulgarian prime
minister five months later can you say
whether your goals will be achieved on
shenen you use the road of path of
trying to
persuade Austria and the Netherlands the
two countries that block our path to
shenen are you prepared to exercise
pressure on these two states with the
mechanisms of the Union would you accept
as a compromise just the lifting of the
control on the air
borders uh another ship is suffering in
the Black Sea Mr denov don't you think
that Bulgaria should pray play a much
stronger role in the dialogue with Putin
do you think that we should leave this
to the other European
countries prime minister Romania and
Bulgaria are captives to Austrian
Chancellor nehammer on the sheman matter
and I know that you are making
diplomatic efforts to unblock uh The
veto of Austria and the Netherlands
reservations I have a question for you
uh as head of the Romanian government
uh at the time I cooperated with the
Bulgarian government in order to um
remove um to lift V visas for Canada and
it was a good effort I'd like to ask you
if you have this kind of cooperation
with your Romanian Partners right now
secondly in these negotiations are you
prepared to accept the certain elements
that could uh positively get the
discussions going that could potentially
get the discussions going in order to
have a clear decision of the council in
December in order for our two countries
to uh enter the shenen area next year
even if this is done uh in at different
dates for the two
countries of course you're not going to
tell us exactly what you're negotiating
on but it's important for us to have
information to
know if there can be a final decision
this year in the council thank
you
your excellencies prime minister I have
a bad news for Chancellor nehammer
Austria is no longer an Empire gone are
the days where the Empress Maria Teresa
put taxes on the Romanian shephards to
make them leave Transylvania and go to
wakia Hungary has billions of Euro
suspended because it doesn't observe the
ru of law Poland the same not Austria
that is blocking the access of Romania
and Bulgaria to shenen and and violates
the treaty with no plausible reason it's
a mystery why the European commission
did not dig infringement procedure
against AA that violated five articles
of the fundamental rights chter of the
by blocking Romania Bulgaria damage of
hundreds of billions of Euro not only
for these countries but for the whole
European economy since F line is
promoting the green deal and want zero
emissions I would like to tell her
something every year trucks waiting even
20 2 4 hours at the border to generate
46,000 tons of carbon dioxide
nevertheless oia has gone Scot free when
the European commission the guardian of
the Tre should ask it to pay uh damage
in the J Council two weeks later Europe
has a historical chance to eliminate the
abuse against the Romanians and
bulgarians in case of a negative vote of
Austria I respectfully ask the members
of the shenen area to show their respect
and support for Romanian Bulgaria and on
their own initiative to stop
discriminating Romanians and Bulgarian
letting them having access to the
European countries by the shenen lanes
of course the Romanians and bulgarians
could control all the trucks cars from
Austria and trains not to have illegal
migrants coming through Austria next
beasi one minute please I ask the
colleagues to stick to their
time thank you president welcome prime
minister denov ladies and gentlemen what
is Europe
today a common project that must become
more and more of a horizon of Hope for
its citizens every day this means making
progress on enlarging shenen as you
rightly stated today guaranteeing
freedom of movement and opportunities
for all just as we need to make progress
with extending the Euro Zone to
strengthen the economy and the internal
Market but one thing must remain clear
to everyone the European Union is not
just a large trading and economic block
Europe is a community of purpose which
rests on the common values enshrined in
the treaties and makes cohesion
solidarity and peace its most powerful
weapons we must reflect this awareness
in our work over the months running up
to the European elections it is
necessary for Europe to speak with one
voice in foreign policy I'm thinking of
Ukraine and the commitment to a peaceful
solution in the Middle East where a
first truce is finally coming and then
strengthening democracy sustainable
growth and inclusion with reform of the
treaties the stability and growth pact
the right of Asylum and consolidating
the health union dear colleagues we have
a date with history it is time today to
regain courage in politics thank you
next is israa for one minute please can
I please ask the colleagues to be quiet
the debate is ongoing
thanks
Madame President Madame commissioner
distinguished Mr Prime Minister dear
colleagues Mr Prime Minister you raised
the issue about how we could contribute
to uh the European Union my answer is
through ambitious and constructive
participation of Bulgaria in the
implementation of the EU policies and
here I will draw your attention to the
energy security and Independence
policies which are part part of the uh
EU PCT what is your opinion about the
potential of the Energy Efficiency
measures and the renewal of the
construction Bond the uh fund
decarbonization from the point of view
of Bulgaria that is strongly dependent
on Russian supplies of energy and has
delayed its plan for a just
transition at the same time we have
inherited
buildings uh constructed according to
the obsolete socialist standard thank
you
minutes thank you Madame
President Mr Prime Minister welcome to
the European Parliament Bulgaria is
right next to the front where
Russia is waging a war against Ukraine
previous Bulgarian governments have
refused to provide military aid to
Ukraine and thus have given the European
Union an impression that the Bulgarian
uh position on the Russian aggression is
not very clear now there's a new
majority in the Bulgarian Parliament and
this uh has been largely overcome but
exactly because of these suspicions
towards Bulgaria it is now important to
to clear up whether Bulgaria is keeping
with the conditions of uh the import of
Russian oil fuk oil that Bulgarian
government has negotiated with the
European
Commission in this regard Bulgaria is an
obligation to notify the European
commission about the implementation of
the Embargo against Russia effective
2014 and secondly on the derogation
decision to notify member states and the
European commission about the ex support
on behalf of L oil uh related to the
exceptions um under environmental risk
so I ask you for a clear answer has the
Bulgarian government done that have you
notified The Bu the member states and
the European commission thank you my
next Vina penov one
minute um Madame President Mr Prime
Minister Madame commissioner Bulgaria
and Romania are part of the European
Union for 17
years those who were born in the year of
our accession are almost uh um of age
and yet we're not members of the
important unions shenen and the Euro
Zone it is not admissible for a whole
generation to be treated as second rate
Europeans the European commission has
repeatedly declared did support for
Bulgaria's membership in these two
organizations two questions to you Mr
Prime Minister how is the our
partnership with Romania developing and
what are the options for joint reactions
and what are were the Diplomatic steps
of uh your government to convince the
states blocking us that the Bulgarian
Nationals cannot be subjected to that
discrimination we are late we started
simultaneous
with Croatia but on account of the
political instability uh in our country
we're lagging behind uh Mr Sher uh I'm a
convinced uh European Social Democrat
and from Austria and I have to say I
think European Solutions and cooperation
is better than veto so therefore I have
to say clearly I do not understand the
Austrian veto against the shenen
membership of Bulgaria and Romania I
think is a big mistake European wise but
also Austrian wise secondly prime
minister being a European I have also to
say I work very much on the enlargement
and I'm very much involved in the
Western balans and therefore I think
also that North Macedonia needs the
support of Bulgaria in order to enter
the European Union they made huge
reforms and they would be your best
friends so please also help North
Macedonia to be quite soon member of the
European
Union thank you Mr sha next Matas n 1
minute
colleagues prime minister Mr denov
welcome to the European
Parliament the series of crises that
we've seen in recent years have had a
profound impact on Europe as well as the
rest of the world and it's been shown
once again that credibility is very
important for the union solidarity
cooperation in the European Union I
think the union is resilient as long as
we are united now it is for that reason
unacceptable that to this very day
Bulgaria and Romania are still standing
at the gates of shenen even though
they've fulfilled the conditions many
many years ago I think it's unacceptable
for this kind of political gamesmanship
to hold back the this European idea of
millions of Europeans I think we need to
put an end to this and we can do that
through the enlargement policy the
enlargement policy which should be based
on objective criteria EU enlargement in
my opinion is the best strategic
guarantee for peace and therefore prime
minister I continue to expect from
Bulgaria a pro-european stance the kind
that you Advocate and we are in favor of
your joining before the Prime Minister
again well
Mr Prime Minister lately in Bulgarian
political debate the notion Europe has
been replaced with Euro
Atlantis and uh for it Bulgaria has uh
given up the right to uh import gas
while this continues to happen in Europe
we have given up on
uh the scope op's ambition and
bulgarians continue to be persecuted in
Scopia in the name of Euro Atlantis we
are on the way of giving up the import
of Russian oil at competitions military
Bulgarian companies have been neglected
in the name of Euro Atlantis we've given
up uh the combat against corruption and
the current Coalition was set up in the
meantime the doors to shenen remain
closed to Bulgaria the recovery and
resilience plan is uh stuck in a Street
and less and less bulgarians vote Mr
Prime Minister I think it's urgent to
clear up what the priorities of your
government are and I hope with the
European elections next year bulgarians
will find a reason to go and vote deno
in order to answer to the questions
posed to him prime minister you have the
floor can I please ask the colleagues to
keep a little bit
quiet
uh Madam president U Madam commissioner
members of the European Parliament I
shall try within five minutes to address
the key issues by starting that the
formation of the Coalition that is
currently ruling Bulgaria was the only
possible pro-european option for forming
a government that would create stability
in the state and I would like to thank
especially Mrs Maria Gabrielle who is
here with me with whom we go to meetings
together in order to convince all who
are still doubting that we can and that
we are ready to work together for the
European development of
Bulgaria from this point of view it is
really disappointing for me that part of
the Bulgarian Ms did not support the
efforts of the debate but tried to bring
in and some kind of division that is
absolutely unnecessary Bulgaria is a
European State and we should develop we
shall work for the European development
of Bulgaria thank you for the comments
thank you that together with the
conservative and liberal values we
should need we should add the Social
Democratic Values the green values
wherever we can find a common solution
for the development of Europe along the
roads that would bring affluence uh and
prosperity of the Bulgarian citizens
nobody has the right to claim to be the
only one uh that can find a solution we
must make efforts to work together so
that over the next years we can
guarantee the Devolution of Europe Mr
jasi asked
me what can the European Union do for
Bulgaria and why did I
uh step back from that idea very often
idea the interests are not opposed
interests are mutual what we can do
together is the best that can help
Bulgaria this is
important this is why it is important
Bulgaria to be integrated in all EU
structures the
shenen area the uh Euro Zone and there
is no contradiction in this on the
questions connected with luk oil the
Russian oil I would like to State very
resolutely from this
rostrom
never has
bugaria violated EU
regulations never has it regul broken
the laws uh luk oil has not violated the
laws with respect to the processing of
oil and oil products therefore any
speculations and rumors along this line
need to be disproved and they will be
disproved with facts I have checked
there are no such viol relations with
respect to
investors I can assure all of you that
the progress attained by Bulgaria over
the past months connected with the rule
of law are already producing results the
monitoring on the Judiciary System of
Bulgaria was lifted Bulgaria ranked
first in the Pro in the sphere of the
progress in the Judiciary the increase
of direct foreign investments by more
than
50% uh is really telling 50% more
foreign investments in Bulgaria this
shows that the efforts of the Bulgarian
government are understood and finally is
there cooperation with Romania yes of
course every one prime minister's
presidents may use different forms of of
expression but Romania and we are
convinced that we must develop the
cooperation in the Balkan Peninsula we
uh initiated trilateral meetings uh
concerning the development of the
infrastructure from Greece across
Bulgaria and Romania to Ukraine and this
is all part of the European effort to
develop the region of the Balkans and I
shall end on the North
Macedonia
um I remember our relations with North
Macedonia in the 90s we were the first
country in the world that
recognized North Macedonia as an
independent uh European State
unfortunately our relations deteriorated
over the years and I don't think that
Bulgaria is to blame I want to State
clearly at present Bulgaria has no
claims to uh and demands to North
Macedonia except those that were
enshrined in the uh treaty there are
relations between North Macedonia and uh
the European Union uh the north maced
North Macedonian should uh comply with
those and this is why I don't accept any
criticism on this very much prime
minister denov thank you for this um
very good debate uh we will move
straight to the vote dear colleagues
thank
you Mr jambbas do you want a point of
order to do with the
votes it is a point of order uh if I
may yeah go ahead I would like to ask
you